I give you Steven contract.
Okay.
Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming out.
Thank you guys for inviting me.
It's good to be back at Google.
I think it's been four or five years since I've been here.
Um,
should,
like I said,
I am an author,
I am a journalist and I'm the CO founder and director of research at the flow
genome project.
And what we studied,
the flow genome project is ultimate human performance or what does it take to be
your best when it matters most.
And what we're really interested in is what does it take for individuals,
organizations,
sometimes institutions to sort of level up their game like never before.
What does it take to achieve paradigm shifting breakthroughs?
Nothing is ever the same again.
Breakthroughs.
And it kind of in a phrase at the heart of the work that I do is really the
question of what does it take to do the impossible?
And it had a serious level of,
you can sort of get past life verbally built into that question.
And uh,
we are in the middle.
No,
it works.
We are in the middle of kind of a giant revolution in our ability to do the
impossible.
And it's a strange revolution.
It is extremely counter intuitive.
It's overturning a lot of conventional wisdom about high performance and it's
going to be the subject of what I talk about today and it's sort of this
revolution is sitting at the intersection of two smaller revolutions in two
overlapping ones.
One is a revolution and peak performance that if you've seen my other Google
talks I talked about,
then we're going to cover a little bit of the same ground and the other is a
revolution.
And what will you could call the science of spirituality.
And I'm using the term spirituality in the most secular possible definition of
the term.
And these two things are colliding and the collision is a really,
really overturning almost everything we knew about human performance.
And um,
as a way of introducing this topic,
I thought I'd start where I started.
I came to the question of how do you accomplish the impossible?
Through a really weird door.
I walked in through the door of journalism.
I became a journalist in the early 1990s and back then,
Action,
Sports,
surfing,
skiing,
rock climbing and whatever,
getting a lot of attention and the x games were starting the gravity games and
there was a lot of work if you could write and ski and right and rock climb or
right.
And Sir,
if there was a lot of work and I couldn't do any of those things very well,
but I needed the work.
So I lied to my editors and I was lucky enough to spend about 10 years chasing
professional athletes around mountains and across oceans.
And I will tell you,
if you're not a professional athlete and you spend all your time chasing
professional athletes around mountains and across oceans tend to break things.
I broke a lot of things as you can see.
And what this meant is I ended up taking a lot of time off,
so I'd be hanging out at snap this or that and I have to take three months,
four months,
five months off.
And when I came back,
the progress I saw was really amazing.
It was leaps and bounds kind of stuff.
It didn't make any sense.
Stuff that was absolutely impossible,
never been done,
never going to be done just three or four months ago,
wasn't just being done.
It was being iterated upon.
And this caught my attention for a lot of reasons,
but it not just the obvious.
If you go back to the of the 1990s action adventure sport athletes,
we're a rowdy punk,
rock,
irreverent bunch of people without a lot of natural advantages.
So most of the people I knew in this community,
they didn't have a lot of education,
they had very little money and most of them had horrific childhood experiences.
And yet here they were on a like semi-regular basis or reinventing what was
possible for our species,
right?
Expanding the limits of physical possibility.
And I want to know what the hell the hell was this possible,
but I'd also broken about 80 bones at that point and I knew what weight one
example,
sorry,
we'll come back to that one example.
I always forget to give this to.
I want to give you one example of what I was looking at.
If you haven't read rise of Superman or aren't familiar with it.
And if you saw my earlier talking,
I'm repeating myself,
I apologize.
We're going to burn through this stuff and get to the new stuff.
Surfing thousand year old sport 480 to 1996 progress is really slow.
25 feet is the biggest wave anybody can serve above that total impossible.
There are physics papers written about how you can't paddle into a wave of 25
feet.
And as you can see from this slide today,
surfers are routinely paddling into waves that are almost a hundred feet tall in
20 years.
And this was happening all over action sports.
So of course I did want to know what the hell was going on and I also knew that
if I didn't take my question out of action sports and into other domains,
I was going to kill myself.
And so that's what I did and I,
that's what I did.
An in kind of all the next eight of my books and for example,
in tomorrow land that was about those maverick innovators who took Saif in
fiction ideas and turn them into science fact technology I bold was wild
business entrepreneurs.
Your own Larry Page,
Jeff Vasos,
Richard Brandson,
folks like that who had um,
Ilan Moscow had invented incredibly world changing businesses in near record
time against crazy odds.
Uh,
in abundance.
I teamed up with Peter Diamandis who co founded the x prize and Singularity
University and we looked at innovators tackling global impossible global
challenges,
poverty,
water scarcity,
energy scarcity,
and making dense here,
right?
And what we discovered,
what I discovered after all this is it doesn't actually matter where you look,
doesn't matter what domain you look in,
wherever you see people forming at the restaurant ever,
you see people tackling the impossible.
You see a state of consciousness known to researchers as flow,
right?
And you may know flow by lots of other names.
Runner's high,
being in the zone,
the forever box.
If you're a standup comic,
play basketball,
it's being unconscious flows a technical term and is technically defined as an
optimal state of consciousness.
When we feel our best and we perform our best and we're so focused on the task
at hand,
everything else just disappears,
right?
Action and awareness will merge.
Sense of self will vanish,
time will dilate.
Fancy way of saying it passes strangely,
it will slow down.
You've got a freeze frame of that.
As soon as it speeds up and five hours go by,
I'm like five minutes.
And throughout all aspects of performance,
mental and physical go through the roof.
Flow science is really old dates back to like the late 18,
seventies,
18,
eighties,
very birth of kind of what became psychology,
what became caught in a neuroscience.
A lot of this work was being done on peak performance way back then.
Um,
got a huge jump forward in the 1970s and eighties when this guy me,
chick sent me Hi often called the godfather of flow psychology.
Uh,
he was the chairman of the University of Chicago Psychology Department and did a
giant kind of enormous study on Optima psychology,
positive psychology one around the world asking me what the Times in the lives
they felt their best and they perform their best.
And he taught us for really kind of fundamental things about flow.
It's worth than that one.
The first thing is the state is definable.
It's got core characteristics and I named some of these for you a second ago.
Absolute concentration,
the present moment,
the merger of Action Awareness,
the vanishing itself time dilation because it is definable,
it's measurable.
We have really well established psychometric instruments for measuring flow.
Um,
over and over and over and over they've been examined.
They're really solid.
So it's definable and is measurable.
It's also universal check sent me high,
discovered that we are all biologically hardwired for flow.
This is how we perform at our best.
So the state shows up anywhere in anyone provided certain initial conditions are
met.
You also named Flo.
And it's for a very specific reasons.
So when he was running around the world asking people about the times and let
them perform their best,
people say the same thing.
They said,
well,
when I feel this way,
I ended up in a state where every action,
every decision flows seamlessly,
effortlessly,
perfectly from the last.
So flow is a phenomenological description,
right?
It describes how the state makes us feel.
Interestingly,
if you'll look under that phenomenology,
you see something really neat for flow to feel flowy,
very disect dishes,
interaction of proceed from seamlessly and fluidly and African.
Recently from the last you're looking at high speed,
near perfect decision making,
right and near perfect.
I need to emphasize not perfect decision making it all.
That's a fallacy.
Scott Schmidt,
who one of the early extreme skiers had a great phrase flow use to make me feel
like superman up until the moment I'm not.
And key important safety tip when it comes to this stuff.
Um,
the last thing you discovered is that flow is fundamental.
It is fundamental to wellbeing,
to meaning to overall life satisfaction.
When do studies of overall life satisfaction and meaning and wellbeing,
people who have the most flow in their lives or the people who score off the
charts.
Um,
and this is another extremely well established finding in the next question that
people kind of turn their attention to after chickson my highs foundational work
is,
okay,
this is optimal performance.
How often,
what the hell are we talking about?
The answer is pretty optimal in sports and athletics.
We now know that flow pretty much to the heart of any gold medal Vladik
championship that's ever been one significant progress in business or excuse me,
in science and technology.
I said earlier,
I studied paradigm shifting breakthroughs.
Whenever you tend to see paradigm shifting,
breakthroughs in science technology tend to see flow.
Same thing with massive progress in the arts.
In business,
we have some really compelling data.
A Mckinsey took a look at flow and the peak performance and they found that
after a long study that top executives report being five times more productive
in flow.
That's 500% more productive or at that means you go to work on Monday,
spend Monday in a flow state and take Tuesday through Friday off and get the
same amount done.
I had two days a week and flow.
And you're 1000% more productive than the competition.
And I will tell you,
even though we're not going to talk about business at all,
I will say my organization,
a lot of other organizations,
we're training up a lot of different organizations,
including you guys.
And we'll talk about the work we did with you guys at Google a little bit later.
But,
uh,
what I wonder is when you look at those numbers and those numbers are pretty
solid,
um,
how they hell do you keep up if you're not doing this stuff?
That's just an open question.
We're not going to linger there.
The next thing that happened kind of after we figured out that flow is at the
heart of all this optimal performance is there's been a revolution in
neuroscience,
right?
Um,
biotechnology right now is moving at five times the speed of Moore's law,
right?
And he's doubling the power of roughly every four months.
And it is dragging neuroscience along in his dragon flow science long.
And this is by the way,
one example of a flow research.
So this is an experiment designed by Baylor Stanford neuroscientist,
David Eagleman back when he was at Baylor.
And uh,
I've been hoisted 150 feet into a circus.
I'm wearing a perceptual chronometer on my wrist and we're trying to figure out
why time passes a strangely and flows.
So I've been dropped,
I'm free falling 150 feet and trying to keep track of time and I will tell you,
we did make some progress on that question.
I'll talk about that in a second.
It also like six and a half months,
a chiropractic work til I could walk straight.
So,
so I want you to know that like I suffered for this information.
People,
that's all I'm saying.
Um,
so what we've learned in a lot of this new neuroscience is that our old ideas
about high performance and things exactly backwards,
the old idea that you guys are familiar with,
it's this so called 10% brain myth.
This is the idea that it a one time we'd use a small portion of our brain,
say 10%,
right?
So flow,
Aka ultimate performance must be the full brand on overdrive,
right?
Turns out we had it exactly backwards inflow.
We're not using more of the brand,
we're using less technical term,
transient hypofrontality,
transient meaning temporary hypo,
the opposite of hyper h.
Y p.
O it means to slow down,
to shutdown to he and fatalities.
This part of the brand,
that prefrontal Cortex,
right?
The portion of your brand that has a lot of your executive functions,
higher cognitive functions,
complex logical decision making,
your sense of morality or sense of will,
longterm planning.
And this is all pre frontal cortex to burns off in flow.
It's an efficiency exchange.
Um,
but as a result we see some really cool things for performance.
For example,
what happens when your prefrontal cortex turns off?
Well,
that's what happens to time.
Time is actually a calculation performed by a bunch of different structures all
over the prefrontal cortex.
And when starts them start to wink out,
we can't separate past from present and future were plunged into this space.
People talk about as the eternal present,
the elongated now the deep now.
All right,
so that's why time passes a stranger than flow.
Huge impact on performance.
Why?
Most of our fears,
stuff we're scared about is either horrible stuff that happened in the past that
we'd like to avoid happening in the present,
right?
Or it's scary stuff that might happen in the future and we'd like to avoid from
the present,
right?
But right here,
right now,
unless you're facing mortal Kombat,
there's not a whole hell of a lot to be afraid of,
right?
So when we drop into flow and drop into this deep now anxiety,
plumbing,
stress hormones literally leave our system.
Same thing happens to your sense of self.
Self is a network effect.
It's produced by a bunch of different structures in the prefrontal cortex.
Couple of other parts of the brain talking to each other.
Like any network,
right?
A bunch of nodes start collapsing,
haul network goes down,
we lose our ability to create our sense of,
again,
huge impact on performance.
When our self goes away,
our inner critic,
that nagging always on to feed his voice in your head,
it goes away as well,
right?
So what do we see?
Risk taking goes up creativity because you're no longer doubting all year need
ideas goes through the roof and we experienced this as liberation freedom.
We are literally getting out of our own way simultaneously.
We see a big shift in brainwaves.
Normally where we are right now,
you're all in Beta.
It's a fast moving brainwave,
right?
It's where we are.
We're paying attention,
we're awake.
Alert flow actually takes place on the border.
That in between Alpha and data,
these are much slower waves.
Alpha is daydreaming.
Mode is the brain from going from idea to idea without a lot of internal risks,
existence,
it's often the signature brainwave for creativity though that research needs
more work.
Um,
Feta is where we are in rem sleep is the hypnogogic state.
So instead of moving from thought to thought without a lot of resistance,
there's zero resistance.
The green turtle becomes the green sweater,
becomes the green planet,
right?
So they haven't got to get to flow is on the borderline.
Now what's interesting about this particular borderline is also when you're in
theta,
you also get another way of called gamma.
It's a very fast,
sharp spiking wave.
It is the signature of the Aha moment.
Gamma only shows up in the brain when the brain is combining new ideas together
for the first time.
It's what's known as binding,
right?
It's what's the signature of the Aha moment?
Gammon,
they'd are coupled waves,
which means you can only get one with the other.
So what this technically means is from a creativity boosting perspective,
flow puts you on the edge of Aha insight at all times.
If you're really want to understand how flow helps us to do the impossible,
you need to know that the state cocktails,
five of the most potent neurochemicals the brain can produce,
right?
Flow appears to be the only time we get all five at once.
All of these boost physical performance,
right?
They speed up muscle reaction times,
increased strength,
increased dexterity,
lower our threshold.
Haydn,
our threshold,
the pain.
More important.
If you really want to know how they impact our ability to tackle impossible
problems,
it's their impact on the three sides of the high call,
what I call the high performance Congo.
This is motivation,
learning and creativity.
And I'm going to sort of break them down one at a time for you.
Cause I think it's critical.
Most of motivation goes through the roof and flow.
Why?
Besides being performance in Hanson Chemicals,
the five chemicals that show up in flow are all pleasure drugs.
In fact,
of the five most potent pleasure drugs the brand can produce and flow gives you
all five at once.
It is a huge high.
So when Mckinsey finds the top executives or 500% more productive in flow,
it's addictive neurochemistry that's underneath that you'd spike and creativity.
But it's why psychologists talk about flow is the store's code of intrinsic
motivation.
We see some least similar with creativity.
So we've made a lot of progress recently and kind of the neuroscience of
creativity.
And one of the things we,
we always know it a really simple level.
It's always a common detory process.
It's what happens when the brain takes and novel information combines it with
older ideas to create something startlingly new flow.
And these neurochemicals more specifically surround that process.
So when we're in flow,
we take in more information per second.
So data acquisition goes up,
we pay more attention to that incoming information.
So salient goes up,
we find faster connections between that incoming information and older ideas.
So pattern recognition goes up kind of farther flung connections between that
incoming information and all their ideas.
So lateral thinking goes up.
And then since creativity also requires you to take your cool innovative idea
and make it public right on the back end of the whole thing,
we see risk taking spike,
I'm in flow.
So flow sort of surrounds the creative process,
which is why in studies or in by my organization,
the flow genome project,
some stuff done at Harvard and some stuff done at the University of Sydney.
We see creativity and flow spikes and 400 and 700% and that sounds like a huge
spike.
It's crazy.
Uh,
we just finished a big creativity study,
got some interesting data and I'm going to talk about it later,
but for now we'll just stop there.
But that spike is not out of line.
And what we see with productivity and nor is it outline what we see with
learning.
Learning also has a huge impact.
These neurochemicals,
quick shorthand for how learning and memory work in the brain.
More neuro chemicals that show up during experience,
better chance that experience is going to move from short term holding to
longterm storage flows.
A huge neurochemical spike.
All right.
As a result,
studies run by the dod and our friends at advanced brain monitoring found that
soldiers and flow can learn 430% faster than normal.
Huge number again.
And what it suggest is like we've all heard about the temp fabled 10,000 hours
to mastery,
which are not accurate,
but that's besides the point.
Um,
what the research does show is that flow can cut them in half.
And all of this is amazing.
All of this is kind of the foundation for the revolution and high performance.
We're going to come back to this stuff in a minute,
but I,
I want to jump and jump towards the second half and I want to retell you the
same story.
Cup few different players from a different perspective.
I lied you earlier when I said it was going to be about the science and
spirituality.
It's really going to be more technically about the science of mystical
experiences and that science also dates back to roughly the same person.
William James.
All right,
we're going to talk in a retail the same story.
William James was not just interested in flow.
He was interested in essentially the entire ecstatic spectrum.
These are all the experiences at the kind of upper range of human experience.
Flow states,
states of awe,
trance states,
meditative states,
contemplatives states,
psychedelic states.
Um,
back then,
by the way,
flow was treated as a mystical experience.
James wrote about it.
He pointed out that it has a huge impact on performance,
but he thought it was a mystical experience.
That's what he thought he was looking at.
Um,
and William James was looking at all of these experiences,
sort of what's known as the Ecstatics,
bactrim.
And he said,
wow,
you know,
whatever you feel about the context,
right?
They may come out of religious traditions,
they may be spiritual.
He said,
that's fine,
but if you would get past that and you look at the data,
the data shows you three things.
It says that all of these states,
interestingly,
they all make you feel roughly the same.
And we'll go,
we'll come back to that in a second.
But there phenomenologically very similar.
They all seem to impact performance.
And even though they may be based on religions that I as a scientist don't
believe in,
they have psychologically real impacts.
People on the other side of these experiences are definitely different.
They lives are more meaningful,
they're more fulfilled.
And for those reasons alone,
you have to take them seriously.
Freud came along and said,
no,
we don't.
Not at all.
We're not going to take those ideas seriously.
You're out of your mind for,
you know,
when we agreed with Mark's,
he thought religion was the opiate of the masses.
He wanted nothing to do with it and more importantly for I'd said,
no,
psychology is about solving pathological problems.
We are not interested in psychological positive possibilities.
That's not what we do here.
Flow got away with it because in the 1950s Abraham Maslow who is also back on
this list was studying success and he found flow in a as as this kind of giant
secret to success and everybody who was doing the studying outward,
Einstein and Eleanor Roosevelt and people like that wanting to know how they
achieve what they had achieved and they all found ways to produce flow and use
it to amplify performance.
But everybody in his study group was an atheist.
So mystical experiences,
what James called it when I was out and peak experiences was with more secular
term that Maslow,
you would just,
and that's when the split occurred,
but there was another lineage which was the science of spirituality and it
didn't really do much.
But in the 1950s this guy,
this is wilder Penfield,
he is one of the great neurosurgeons in the 20th century.
It was an epilepsy expert expert and back in the 1950s he was doing all these
experiments where all these procedures where he would open up people's brain,
brain,
skull and which you can do,
um,
it's not a whole lot of nerves there so you can do with local anesthetic and
keep people awake and he was stimulating different portions of people's brains
in epileptics trying to produce not a seizure but an aura,
which is what it's often a violent shift in perception that precedes a seizure.
Um,
people will see colors or smells,
smell of burnt toast is really common anyways,
going through people's brains trying to produce these reactions.
Once he found a spot,
he would scoop it out.
And that was certain brain surgery,
right?
For epilepsy.
But when he started stimulating people's right temporal lobe and the plate,
the temporal parietal junction where those lobes coming together,
weird stuff started to happen.
People that out of body experiences,
p bull herd visions,
they had hallucinations,
they had sense presence,
which is the peeling of a god or a ghost or a demon in the room with them.
And for the first time somebody went,
hey,
wait a minute,
there's biology underneath our mythology,
whatever else is going on,
there's biology there now.
Real Science of course,
doesn't study this stuff and they didn't until this man Andy Newberg came along
in the late 1990s and Andy is an incredibly brave man who risked his career to
ask a really interesting question and he was really interested in consciousness
who was the University of Pennsylvania and he felt that if you were interested
in consciousness,
you absolutely had to account for the phenomenon known as unity or cosmic unity
becoming one with everything.
And the reason you have to account for it is oneness with everything shows up in
every single mystical tradition on earth.
It's an every religion honor and it's there long before there's mass
communication.
So if it's everywhere and it's there before there's mass communication,
there's probably biology under neath it because it doesn't seem like the whole
world is having a mass hallucination.
Right?
It doesn't make sense.
Right.
So there's probably some biology there.
He wanted to know what is the biology and he took a look.
He,
so he took a bunch of Tibetan Buddhists and a bunch of Franciscan nuns who both
experience absolute unity through their meditation practices.
For the nuns.
It's Hooni a mystical oneness with Jesus,
his love for the Buddhists.
It's absolute unitary being oneness with the universe.
Right.
And what he discovered is more hypofrontality but not quite.
What he discovered is this portion of the brain down here,
it's not as the orientation area gets very,
very quiet.
It's another efficiency exchange in the same way the prefrontal cortex and runs
off.
And this portion of the brain is the right parietal lobe.
It's right at the temporal parietal junction,
right at the same spot.
Wilder,
Penfield noticed all this activity and what Newburgh discovered is this portion
of the brand,
by the way,
um,
he calls it the orientation area cause it helps us orientate ourselves in space.
What it does is it basically there was a boundary around the body and says,
at this point,
this is where you end and the rest of the world begins and you need this
boundaries.
You can walk across a crowded room without bumping into people or people who
have a stroke or brain damage to this area.
They can't sit down on a couch because they're not quite sure where their leg
ends in.
The couch begins during intense concentration in meditation.
When the brain needs extra energy fo focus,
it takes it away from this area.
This area shuts down no energy and no energy out as a result because you can no
longer separate from self,
self from other.
The brain includes has to conclude at this particular moment,
you're one with anything,
everything.
So this is where the stories come back together in the Uber did this research in
the early two thousands I was at that point studying surfers who were doing
amazing things and they kept coming to me saying,
hey man,
when I'm out there,
when I'm surfing a tube,
I am one with the ocean and it kept happening and I was a surfer and I knew what
they were talking about because I had had that experience and I just wrote about
wrote it off and never talked about it out loud cause what could be flaky and
then a surfer running around talking about being one with the ocean.
Right.
It's terrible.
And yet it was all over the place.
Everywhere in surfing and we're going to doctor Newburgh and I Sandy,
is it possible we're looking at the same thing.
Could the oneness with everything the servers are looking at be the one that's
with everything.
The Buddhists are looking at the concentration and we did some work on it and
thought about it a lot.
And the answer is yes,
of course,
the amount of concentration you need to ride a wave as the same amount of
concentration you need for prayer and meditation.
Um,
now it seems so obvious back then,
it was a big step forward.
It was also the first of a bunch of step forwards along similar lines.
So over the past 20 years,
neurotheology since Dr Newburg discovered oneness with everything,
we have looked at pretty much every elder's date you can possibly imagine,
and every so-called mystical state you can possible.
Imagine prayer states contemplate if states states of all trans states,
psychedelic states,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And what we discovered is that William James was totally right.
I mean,
he was so ahead of his time.
It was crazy from a neurological perspective,
from a phenomenological perspective,
all these states,
and these are some weird states.
So what you're saying is a surfer inflow riding a wave is experiencing the same
thing as a Zen Buddhists.
Meditating in a monastery is experiencing the same thing as somebody at burning
man on a psychedelic.
That's pretty odd.
But that is exactly,
it.
Turns out what we seem to be discovering neuro,
the neuro biological,
this entire ecstatic spectrum.
We see the same three things,
right?
We see the prefrontal cortex deactivate.
And then if the state is really intense,
we see activation and deactivation at the temporal parietal junction.
We see brainwaves dropped down to the Alpha Theta borderline and we see some
combination of these big five neuro chemicals.
We also see a lot of phenomenological over them.
All of these states,
it doesn't matter if we're talking meditative states,
states of Oss,
I get Alec States,
flow states selfless is consistent in all of them by the way.
Uh,
to get it this list,
um,
I should back up a,
I wrote,
uh,
stealing fire,
which is the book that I'm talking about with my partner Jamie wheal and the
flow genome project.
And one of the bits of research that we did is everybody and their mother from
William James Forward hasn't altered a way of defining alders dates and measure
melter states and thinking about all the dates.
And the problem with most of them is they're very context dependent.
So when Buddhist talk about what they experienced in meditation or in trance,
you get very Buddhist interpretations.
And the same thing with Christians and blah blah.
If you go back to the 60s and even if you were dealing with like sixties
psychologists,
there was all kinds of rebirthing stuff coming up.
So you have versions of altered states spectrums that have Neil Natal,
this and that,
and we wanted something that was context independent.
We're just interested in how it makes you feel,
how it shifts feelings.
And that's it.
And this is what we've come up with.
Um,
it has not completely validated.
We've run it by tons of researchers.
A lot of people find it very,
very useful,
has not been validated.
There may be something we're missing,
but we're certain about this stuff,
selflessness,
because the prefrontal cortex turns off timelessness because the prefrontal
cortex turns off.
Effortlessness is this feeling in mystical experiences.
We talk about this as being propelled by gods are ghosts are forces beyond our
control.
And in flow we talk about this as effortless effort,
right?
And what it really is,
is it's five of the most addictive neurochemicals.
The brand can produce showing up in your system and making things feel amazing
and you obviously want more of it.
And the richness refers to information richness.
And the idea is quite simple.
I used the same way that creativity is amplified.
It's amplified in all these states because all these states surround the
creative process and amplify and we get lots and lots of data and we're seeing
this is where the revolutions come together.
We're actually seeing both sides of the coin.
So Freud said psychology has to be about curing the SEC.
And that's what we're seeing and we're seeing because the states are very,
very similar because they're neuro,
biologically similar.
There's similar in impact.
So I want to talk about what we're seeing in PTSD research.
So I said earlier that flow can be useful treating anxiety because it resets the
nervous system.
PTSD is the most extreme anxiety disorder we have and we suck at treating it
generally,
right?
SSRI is the only kind of known treatment for Ptsd.
25 million Americans,
by the way,
are suffering PTSD at any one time.
So it's an epidemic,
right?
And all we've got for them as Sris,
which a you have to take for the rest of your life,
be they don't work on everyone and there's a ton of treatment resistant
depression and PTSD.
They rarely work in women.
Um,
they're not great drugs.
So about 10 years ago,
Rick Doblin and the Multidisciplinary Association for Psychedelic Research said,
hey,
let's try psychedelic therapy now.
Psychedelic therapy combines a psychedelic and talk therapy,
right,
blends it together.
And they tried to Mtma therapy on soldiers returning from Afghanistan and Iraq
with PTSD,
victims of child abuse and victims of sexual abuse.
And what they discovered is one to three sessions of p of Mtma therapy.
So using the same psychedelic Mtma that's inside of ecstasy or Molly
was enough to significantly reduce or completely cure PTSD.
And it's been six years since of studies have been run and we know that it's
persistent,
it stays gone.
Nobody's had to go back from further treatments.
So exciting is this to the FDA that they've fast tracked Mgma as a treatment for
PTSD.
And we're going to see it's already in phase three trials and we're going to see
it as a medicine by 2020.
In fact,
the FDA was so impressed with MDM and its ability to treat PTSD that they're now
looking at it as a treatment for regular depression and anxiety.
Um,
so that is moving forward.
Not everybody wants to do with psychedelic to deal with their PTSD.
Okay.
Said the dod at Camp Pendleton,
they rerun the exact same study this time they swapped out the psychedelic,
they put in flow,
they use surfing and talk therapy,
put over a thousand soldiers through this protocol.
And what did they discover?
Because the neurobiology is very similar.
Five weeks of surfing and talk therapy was enough to significantly reduce or
completely cure PTSD in returning soldiers.
Then the Dod said,
okay,
that's cool.
Let's try it again.
With Meditation,
they did four weeks of mantra based meditation.
20 minutes a day was enough to significantly reduce PTSD.
And when I say significantly reduce,
I mean they're off their meds or significantly off their meds or it's completely
gone.
So three different approaches,
three different altered states,
right,
that you would not normally associated with one another yet very similar
impacts.
And we see this on the curing side of the equation.
We also see it on the high performance side,
right?
We see,
we talked earlier about flows,
impact on creativity.
While there's some really cool research that was done in the Netherlands for
example,
where they were looking at open senses,
Meditation,
um,
this is where you're taking in information and you're not judging it too
harshly,
but it's not mantra focus.
Meditation opens his,
his meditation tends to be very,
very good for divergent thinking.
Focus Meditation is good for convergence.
It turns out,
but they're seeing a,
in the studies,
they were on three 45 minute open monitoring meditation sessions,
enough to significantly increase fluency,
flexibility,
originality and elaboration,
which are four key characteristics of uh,
creativity and microdosing,
which your sob,
perceptual doses of psychedelics,
right?
So you're taking small,
small doses of psychedelics.
Microdosing James,
Matt Up.
His research is founded on average,
you're getting a 200% boost in creativity.
And I'm just the list.
So this is a list.
The regional microdosing creativity study was done here in Silicon Valley,
was done back in the 60 was the last legal study done before they shut down LSD
research and literally they shut it down the next day,
but he took a bunch of people from the valley and he said,
okay,
all you guys was people who were selected because they had spent months trying
to solve a hard technical creative challenge and gave them my giving microdose
sub perceptual doses of loosening and this is the list of some of the stuff that
came out the other side that was incredibly useful improvement to a magnetic
tape recorder,
math theorem regarding nor gates new model will photon space probe to measure
solar properties,
new building design on and on,
right?
So huge practical boosts and creativity.
We're seeing the same thing.
In fact,
you saw early on that list technologically mediated states,
really crazy study done at the University of Australia and creativity and flow.
They took a bunch of people and they gave them the nine dot problem to solve.
You've seen this connect nine dots with four lines in 10 minutes without lifting
your pencil from a paper,
right?
Under normal conditions,
less than five people,
5% of people can solve it in their study group.
Nobody did.
Then they use transcranial magnetic stimulation.
They artificially knocked out the prefrontal cortex by sending a weak magnetic
pulse.
So it's artificially induced.
Transient hypofrontality artificially produces 20 to 40 minute flow state,
50% of their study groups solve that problem in record time.
So we're seeing on all all these wildly different states,
same impact on both sides of the spectrum.
They have potential to really treat intractable conditions and they have the
potential to massively improve performance.
This,
by the way,
just in case you're curious,
the one thing I haven't talked about,
we talked about neuroanatomy,
neuro chemistry,
and our electricity,
which are three of the things you need to talk about to talk about brain stuff.
We did not talk about networks,
but just so you have some idea of where that heightened creativity is.
Uh,
when you're on psychedelics,
this is work done by Robin Carhart Harris.
He's at imperial college doing really great imaging studies on psychedelics.
We've teamed up with them to do the very first flow and psychedelic side by
side,
comparative contrast,
altered states study on that.
We're going to be launching I think first week of June.
Um,
so coming up.
But anyways,
on the left side,
this is your brain brain connectivity on under normal conditions on the right
side,
that is what your brain looks like in Siliciden.
It is the most network connectivity we see in the brain.
That is why creativity is going through the roof.
This is also why we're now seeing this is the cover of the economist and it's
still makes my brain explode to look at it term tune on,
turn on and drop by the office.
It is about microdosing at work and it's the cover of the economist.
So yeah,
this stuff is really going,
starting to go mainstream.
And the best news of all is that this consciousness is incredibly,
incredibly,
incredibly hackable and you don't actually have to take itself psychedelic
substance.
So on the flow side.
Talked a little bit of a second because I want to jump back to flow.
One of the things that we've discovered very,
very recently is that flow states have triggers.
These are preconditions that lead to more flow.
So if you're interested in kind of hacking your consciousness with this stuff,
these 20 triggers are your toolkit and we have individual triggers.
There are 10 or 11 of these that will drive an individual into flow.
And then we have group triggers.
This is the product of key soils.
Researchers at the University of North Carolina and there are 10 group trekkers
and group triggers will drive a team and to flow produce a collective shared
flow state known as group flow,
right?
You've taken part in a great brainstorming session where the ideas are flying
off the wall.
That's group flow and action.
If we've seen a fourth quarter comeback and football or basketball,
that's group flow in action.
Um,
and you can talk a little bit more about these triggers in a second.
But the one thing I want to tell you just so you know,
is flow follows focus only shows up on all our attention isn't the right here
right now.
That's what these triggers do.
They drive our attention into the present moment.
More specifically,
not all of them,
but most of them tend to drive norepinephrine and dopamine,
which are our main focus and chemicals.
That's really what's going on under the hood.
Now I want to a,
I don't want to leave you hanging.
I want to give you some practical advice.
So I said we just did a giant study on creativity and flow.
Um,
it was,
it was interesting,
but 2100 people took part.
And what we were looking at is among other things,
what triggers are most associated with heightened creativity?
Um,
first we wanted to look at the big numbers that create creativity with this 400
to 700% spike.
We were like,
well,
what the hell is that?
What?
What's actually,
what do we mean by creativity?
So we broke creativity down.
We looked at the process portions of creativity.
And so we found that idea generation,
for example,
goes up 40% problem solving goes up 40% and so you start to see where those big
numbers come from cause these things start to stack on one another.
We also found three triggers are most associated with creativity across the
board in knowledge workers,
right?
So what everybody in this room does for a living.
The first is obvious complete concentration flow follows focus only shows up
when we're in the right here right now.
But what that means by the way,
is the research shows us that you need 90 to 120 minutes of uninterrupted
concentration and really maximize flow.
So that means you need 900 120 minutes where your office door can be shut,
where your phone is off,
where your email is off.
We're Facebook is off where Twitter is off.
It means if you're running a team right and you're telling your team members
that they have to email you back in a half an hour,
you're literally locking that team out of the very state of consciousness.
They need to maximize performance.
For example.
It's why when I go into organizations,
I always tend to save.
You can't hang a door sign on your door that says,
beep off,
I'm flowing.
You're sunk.
Right?
Next thing we see with creativity is it requires the challenge skills balance
often called the golden rule of flow.
Most important flows triggers the idea is that we pay the most attention to the
right here,
right now.
Task at hand when the challenge of the task at hand slightly exceeds our
skillset.
So you want to stretch but not snap emotionally.
This means flows sits not on but near the midpoint between boredom,
not as stimulation.
I could give a shit and anxiety.
He whoa.
Way Too much stimulation right in between is this sweet spot.
Um,
finally,
immediate feedback.
This should come as no surprise here at Google,
but you know,
this is one of the reasons by the way,
we saw so much flow and action.
Sports mass and actions where if you have immediate feedback,
you're a skier.
You don't set that edge at the top of the raw and you're on a face first death
slide to the bottom.
It's really obvious.
Same thing happens in software,
of course,
agile software,
the entire agile movement,
right,
was about tightening up feedback loops.
And one of the reasons is it maximizes creative flow,
right?
And so obviously,
you know,
in business for example,
if you've got quarterly reports or annual reports,
and that's the only feedback you're getting,
it's a disaster for this stuff.
Um,
the last thing I wanna tell you about the triggers is,
um,
they're remarkably easy to train.
And if you would've come to me five years ago,
in fact,
the last time I spoke here in two times ago
and said,
what,
what do you believe about flow?
What would you bet your house on?
I would've bet my house that this stuff is massively hard to train.
Absolutely.
Turns out we were deadly wrong about that.
Um,
the example is,
uh,
two or three years ago,
thanks to Adam Leonard,
um,
we teamed up with you guys and ran a six week joint learning exercise,
right?
And over a course of six weeks,
we took about 70 Googlers from all over the company.
So facilities and sales and marketing and coding and engineering.
And take your pick and we train people up.
Um,
but an hour's worth of homework a day in four high performance basics,
I mean basics like sleep hygiene,
right?
Get enough sleep at night and then put yourself on a sleep monitor to take care
of it.
Um,
and uh,
the use of really what amount to do for flow triggers.
And on the back end of that we tested flow pre and post.
We found a 35 to 80% increase and flow,
I'm here now it's a little high,
but because people self selected to be in that class,
right?
They were already interested in the topic.
So those numbers are probably a little skewed.
But I will tell you,
we have a digitally delivered course called flow fundamentals.
And it's the same thing,
same similar structure.
We were a little more intensive than what we did here.
But again,
we measure pre and post and on average and thousands of people who have taken
this course.
By now we're seeing a 70% increase in each of flows metrics.
And this doesn't mean our Kung Fu is exceptionally bad ass,
which it is.
What it really means is that this stuff is really easy.
We're all biologically hardwired for it.
Um,
which is really,
really cool and we're getting options,
right?
This is the transcranial magnetic stimulation I talked about.
Um,
because pattern recognition is so heightened and flow radar operators is a radar
operator in the u s military are using it before they go on shipped stockbrokers
because you can see so much more patterns in Wall Street are doing this before
they're going onto the trading floor.
We're seeing similar things in Hegi Development,
right?
Back in the 1990s at the same time,
Andy Newberg was doing his really brave work.
Another guy named Richard Davidson started recording the brainwaves of monks,
Tibetan Buddhists,
who had 30 years of meditation time and he discovered some really cool things
that their brain waves essentially sit on the edge of flow at all times and that
there's yelled huge amount of gamma,
which you want for extra creativity in their brainwaves.
But who the hell has 30 years,
let alone 30 hours,
right?
So what did we do?
Well,
we recorded those brainwaves and now using neurofeedback and Eg,
we are training to people to move in the same direction in three weeks,
three months,
very compressed timeframes.
Um,
in fact,
if you want more flow in your life,
the same technology is available to you.
Go to the flow genome project.com.
There's a free flow profile there.
Um,
under the learn tab,
it's a diagnostic radiologist says if you're this kind of person,
you're likely to find flow in these directions.
It's become one of the largest studies on an optimal performance.
Verano another killed another longstanding darling.
We thought when we started this work flow absolutely must show up the most
action adventure,
sport athletes.
Um,
and in sort of performing arts people in bands,
people on stage.
That question turns out now the vast majority of our studies that we just have
to be like 80,000 people have taken the study at this point are knowledge
workers.
They do what everybody in this room does for a living.
The most flow tends to show up in knowledge work.
Alright,
wrap this all up.
I want to give you one sort of big picture.
Look at all this stuff,
so stealing fire,
origin story.
I was writing a book called rise of Superman,
about flow and I was talking to Salim Ismail who was at that point,
the executive director of singularity university and Seleme,
a former director of innovation at Yahoo,
really interested in flow and innovation and we were talking any,
he's pointed out,
he's like,
you know Steven,
if you think about it,
every time you go to a sporting event,
all right,
if you go to a basketball game,
you're playing to see players and flow,
and he said,
if you go to see a movie,
you're going to see actors and flow and you're hoping to get a director was in
flow.
When they shut the movie,
you're a poetry reading on.
He said,
I bet it's a large portion of the GDP,
and that caught our attention.
They caught my attention and I started thinking about it and when we started
doing the research for stealing fire and figuring out that,
hey,
wait a minute,
flow,
meditative states caught ablative states,
psychedelic states,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
All these things are very,
very similar.
We said,
well let's try to measure that.
Let's measure the altered state economy.
How much money do people spend chasing this experience of selflessness,
timelessness,
effortlessness and richness.
Right?
And I'm not going to walk you through the calculation.
It is in the footnotes to stealing fire,
police hammer on it,
run your own calculations and I spent a year working on it.
I want it to get as rigorous as possible cause it's mindblowing in what it tells
us.
And the first thing I also want to point out is not all of this stuff is
positive,
right?
What I'm telling you about selflessness and effortlessness and information rich
and all this stuff.
Some people seeking it out,
they're going and doing meditation retreats,
retreats or developing a yoga practice or they're pursuing flow and a lot of
people are just taking a lot of drugs,
right?
There's a negative downside,
dark side to all of this as well.
And we measured that as well.
But when we were done,
you know,
are very conservative calculation came up with a figure that is $4 trillion a
year.
It is one 16th of the global economy that we spend trying to get out of our
head,
trying to shift our consciousness in this way.
And as you can see from the stuff I'm talking about,
those numbers,
because we're getting very precise,
we're getting better at this,
right?
We're being able to tune this in ways like we never could before and being able
to get some more of the positive benefits in less than the negative benefits.
This is only going to grow over time.
Um,
and I think the last thing I want to tell you today is that I think all of this
information puts kind of a wonderful and yet really terrible burden on each and
every one of us.
Cause you got to ask yourself,
right,
what kind of impossible challenges are you going to go after?
If you could be 500% more productive,
if you could be 600% more creative,
if you could cut your learning times in half.
All right.
The science is pretty overwhelming that that's exactly what is available to each
and every one of you today,
right?
As Alice Walker pointed out so many years ago,
we are the ones we've been waiting for.
But what we choose to do with that information remains entirely up to us.
But thanks for listening and I'm happy to take some questions.
[inaudible]
so I'm wondering if there's any limits in age for flow.
So,
and I'm asking,
I'm coaching my 10 year olds baseball team and uh,
like to hear your thoughts on it.
It's a great question.
Um,
so as you were talking,
um,
I,
I don't know if there were upper limits.
Um,
I really don't,
uh,
age-related limits.
I realized as you were talking,
I was like,
God,
I've never even asked that question or even thought about that.
So there may be upper limit stuff that I don't know about.
Kids are actually very flow prone because developmentally their prefrontal
cortex doesn't finish developing until you're 25.
Right?
So,
um,
that's why your nose is the last thing to grow a space for your prefrontal
cortex.
Right.
Um,
and so they're developmentally geared towards transient hypofrontality and their
brainwaves are actually naturally close to Alpha than we adults are in Beta.
Kids tend to be closer to Alpha.
Um,
so kids are flood prone.
In,
in my book,
rise of Superman,
we talked about like the crazy places is showing up.
Flow coaching is she's gotten into action sports early.
Right.
And we saw it and skating for example,
you routinely see 12 to 14 year old kids when the x Games beating 25 to 35 like
professional athletes.
And one of the reasons is because flow coaching has been in action sports for
longer,
right in mainstream sports at popped in,
uh,
Jimmy Johnson said the Dallas cowboys won the Superbowl back in the 90s and he
credited chicks at me.
Hi.
So it flows been in sports for a while,
but not at the level it,
those traditional batted ball sports are a little more conservative.
Right.
Um,
and action sports,
you know,
they weren't even sports back in the 90s.
Right?
Um,
so there's been a lot more flow coaching.
We're seeing interesting results.
Uh,
a friend of ours,
we are working with,
um,
a guy in Minnesota who is doing a bunch of flow work in grade school and they're
using the flow profile with kids.
Uh,
I'm trying to figure out what's their dominant flow area and then having them do
a lot of independent studies over the years and there the ideas that they can
get them into high school already knowing what produces the most flow in their
life and what they're most passionate about,
they'll have a leg up.
Um,
so we're,
we're doing some of that work.
We're looking at it,
but there's a ways to go.
Thank you.
Sure.
Hi.
They talk once they thinking about this,
I'm sold.
I want to be in flow all the time.
Very productive.
Very great.
Awesome.
But thinking about,
uh,
the chemicals that have heightened levels,
isn't there supposed to be a crash?
Like what?
I know is it,
okay.
So let me stop there.
That's if you were going to say that nobody gets to be in flow all the time are
like,
people come up to me about once a month at night.
Dude,
Steven steeps,
I'm at flow all the time.
You should study me.
And this has been happening for years.
And in the beginning I didn't know what to say.
And now I'm just honest.
I'm like,
absolutely.
We know we have a term for that.
We call that schizophrenia.
Sometimes we call that mania depending,
but it's an either or.
Right?
Flows a cycle.
This is her Benson did a lot of the foundational neuroscience on this.
Um,
and it's a Ford Park Cycle.
And as you pointed out,
those neurochemicals that show up in the flow,
oh,
are expensive for the brain to produce,
right?
They require minerals and some of them require sunlight and some of them require
vitamins and foods and blah,
blah,
blah.
And um,
so there's a recovery time,
right?
Norepinephrine and dopamine for example,
why are Ted talks 20 minutes long?
Because these are your two principal focusing chemicals and they are most of the
exhausted after 20 minutes at peak concentration.
So you've ever seen a James Bond movie,
right?
Everything blows up for the first half an hour and then you're bored to death
for the rest of the time.
Right.
It's cause you've exhausted all your focusing fueled good drugs and now you've
just got bad popcorn on your stomach.
Right?
I mean literally like that's that feeling.
So yes,
on the backside of flow there is a recovery period for sure.
It's built in so nobody gets to live in flow as far as we can tell even.
Uh,
there's some really interesting work.
Some people often miss conflated enlightenment with permanent flow.
Like there's an idea out there that enlightenment might be permanent flow.
We've actually made some really interesting progress on studying so called
enlightenment.
Um,
and the one thing that we're pretty sure it is,
it doesn't appear to be permanent flow.
It seems that it takes the shift in perspective that you get from flow,
that kind of expansive oneness with everything.
It allows you to access it under normal conditions.
Um,
but it doesn't seem to be a permanent flow state.
I don't,
I don't think that's possible outside of a manic episode.
I don't think that's possible.
Thanks.
Sure.
Thanks for asking.
Thank you for this fantastic talk.
So what you essentially a doctor about his meditation one on one,
a lot of the concepts are very similar.
Um,
there are these um,
um,
gadgets,
these tastes,
um,
they call it the brain balancing.
Apparently there are,
they can induce you into your flow state.
Um,
there are certain devices the EEG based which uh,
people with Adhd used to train and that is nothing but attention training.
So you look at a certain pattern on the screen and you focus your attention
thereby,
uh,
tried to do something repeat repeatedly and you slowly get into your flow state
by doing this.
So this is well known,
but the other kind of devices is the claim is that you don't need to do
anything.
You don't need to focus your attention,
but it plays some signals,
some sounds in your ears and apparently it's supposed to divert your state
towards these flow states.
I don't know how much it is.
I call bullshit.
It's VSA.
Okay.
What I found consistently,
is there a lot of people out there who have a device that measures one thing or
does one thing and they want to call it flow.
So we've got this EEG device that drives your brainwaves to the Alpha Theta
border line and it's got to put you into flow.
Well No,
it's going to drive your brainwaves to the Alpha Theta borderline.
Okay.
But flow is changes in network structure is trained in anatomy.
Helical function has changes in neurochemistry.
It's a bunch of physiological reactions that we're just now starting to maybe
measure and nobody's put it all together in one physiological flow detector.
At this point though,
we are working on one,
but anytime I hear a single correlate hypothesis,
it takes your brain waves.
It does this and put it calling it flow to me.
I don't understand that.
Like I don't,
I don't understand why people are doing that when we know flow has total shift
in brand function.
So that's first of all,
when it comes to sound though,
I have friends,
we'll Henshall it.
Focus will um,
brain FM.
There's some really interesting groups doing really good work on sound and flow.
My friend Chris Barker who runs advanced brain monitoring and in Carlsbad,
California,
there,
she's the person who teamed up a with the dod to do the flow in the accelerated
learning stuff.
Um,
it's give a Ted talk.
You can find that online.
One of the things they did is they look at by will beats,
right?
There were 400 companies doing sound would buy on our beats and it's supposed to
put you in flow and whatever.
And they,
she literally like put the most shit they make just about the best EEG
measurement device in the world,
I think.
And uh,
they took every buyer,
no beads program they could find and look for any consistent neurological shift
found nothing that was consistent.
So I'm not saying that there is this technology out there that I'm,
sooner or later somebody is going to crack that.
Right?
There's,
we know from Apple's work with Sovos that,
you know,
the power of music is really amazing in terms of its ability to shift
consciousness.
So there's definitely something there,
right?
But I,
we can't,
we're not,
we're not there yet.
I don't think.
Nothing I've,
and I've seen,
um,
they're probably,
there are probably people out there with like breakthrough technology that could
tell me I'm lying and don't know,
but I haven't seen anything that I comfortable with that I think does that yet.
I think we're getting close to though,
and I,
and I think all this stuff is an exponential growth curves.
So,
you know what seemed absolutely ridiculous three years ago.
You were going to get into two years,
three years.
Thank you.
Sure.
Thanks for coming.
Um,
it's from your comments.
It sounds like you're not a big fan of open office plans,
but a open office plans are super big fat around here.
So my request to you is a,
please rescue us.
What can you do for us?
Yeah,
that's it.
It's a fair point.
Right?
Um,
uh,
and you're not the only one.
There was a couple of years ago,
right when Facebook decided they were going to do away with desks entirely and
put everybody on walking desks facing each other in a circle.
So,
I don't know if that's true or not by the way,
but I just heard it and I was like,
what a disaster for flow.
Um,
that said,
um,
open office plans can be really good for group flow,
right?
Dependent right there.
They have their purpose.
But what I,
you know,
the companies that I,
that I'm seeing that are doing this are building like any of the,
uh,
the,
the Co workspaces that you're seeing pop up.
They have little phone booth rooms that anybody can go into and shut the door
and it's a private little office.
So I'm seeing a lot of companies that like open office plans started to build in
silence pods where you can just close yourself in and lock yourself off.
Um,
and equally important is you've got to have your conversations about this,
right?
If you're not going to,
if you're,
if you've got a manager and you don't,
they're not into this whole idea of what you're doing and something that you're
going off for $90 and 20 minutes and you're coming back and like,
I was in flow,
it's,
you're going to be fired,
right?
Like you've got to,
so it's gotta be done out loud.
I think people have to understand why this is mandatory,
but I think open office plans ultimately,
um,
I think we're going to start to see them go away.
Um,
and I,
you know,
I think some of this is just that we're going to be three d printing office
buildings and we get complexity for free.
So suddenly it's not going to be cost efficient to put everybody in cubicles.
We're going to be at to build whole offices and I think the problem is going to
get solved.
I think it's a money issue less than an open office plan,
a shoe at this point.
But yeah,
they're disasters for flow.
Okay.
Um,
so you talked about the psychedelic drugs,
but I'm curious,
are there studies like seeing how different drugs simulate the flow state,
like cocaine or marijuana?
So,
um,
the neurochemicals,
the big five neuro chemicals,
every time you have,
uh,
a neurochemical,
right,
you have an egg dodginess negative,
exogenous chemical,
right?
So the body produces endorphins.
These are our natural opiates,
right?
So
flow is essentially delve man,
which is cocaine,
right?
Whenever you use cocaine,
all that happens is the brain releases a bunch of delp mean and blocks.
It's re uptake.
Um,
you get a little serotonin that's ecstasy,
you know,
at one pathway or,
or Lsd at another,
an add to mine,
which is you said is t h say,
um,
norepinephrine is essentially speed and uh,
I don't know what I'm forgetting hair.
Um,
but the point is you actually couldn't cocktail those drugs on the street,
which is where the interesting some of them counteract.
You're going to end up dead or in a coma if you try,
right?
What's cool is the brain can cocktail them all naturally and you don't Tan.
I mean,
now this does mean,
you know,
flow has a dark side,
right?
It's a very sticky state.
It's very addictive,
right?
And it's just a,
you know,
chicks at me,
I said flow is different than most other addictions.
Most of their addictions lead backwards flow because it always,
you're always extending your skills because you're walking up that challenge.
Skills balance isn't an addiction that leads forward.
But if you have a high flow lifestyle on the navy seals who we do some work
with,
when the navy seals stop being maybe seals when an action sport athletes stops
being an action sport athlete,
right?
When a rock star stopped being rockstar,
these are massively difficult transitions to handle.
Um,
and a lot of what we're seeing off,
for example,
in soldiers returning from combat and things like that is these are high flow
environments that compared to regular life,
it's really difficult and that's a big portion of the difficulty.
And we're doing some work around that to try to see what we can learn there.
There's a long way to go,
but we're poking at it.
Yeah.
Anybody else?
Yeah,
I'm Doreen.
I'm the first one is,
um,
a bone,
the concept of flow hike,
fast enough podcast.
Uh,
how can we translate flow states,
uh,
the to be achieved through athletic pursuits to everyday life.
Um,
so part of that answer,
um,
did they want me to break down the flow hike or was that
basically,
if I understand the question,
how
we can sort of,
um,
uh,
use the low hike.
Okay.
Um,
okay,
so there's couple of different answers.
The first answer is flows a focusing scale essentially,
right?
Like whoever said it was like meditation one-on-one a lot.
There's a lot of fundamentals there,
right?
We,
we train people in mindfulness is flow follows focus,
right?
So you want to drive that focus into the present tense.
How did I get here?
What did you ask me?
I totally lost my place.
I looked at you,
I did the meditation thing.
What was the question?
Flow.
Hike or flow through athletic pursuits in low flow through the LATIC pursuits,
um,
it tends to translate,
right?
So the flow training that I get while skiing helped me as a writer,
It's the same kind of focus,
right?
So whenever you're training that you're training that.
So they're one,
one is the athletic pursuits will just naturally bleed over into,
into your everyday life.
So in other words,
the more flow you get,
right?
That's across the boards.
The flow hike is,
uh,
is not an athletic pursuit hike.
It's actually a daily flow.
Like you asked about the neurobiology,
right?
So this is a hike I use every day I wake up,
I start writing at four o'clock in the morning.
I right from forward to late am and at 8:00 AM I take my dogs for a hike and
it's a hike specifically designed to put me into flow.
Um,
meaning of my writing session was really unpleasant.
If I was struggling a bunch,
this is going to put me into flow on the back end.
And so when I come back to our co,
I'll be refresh and if it was a flow state,
it's a good way to reset my system.
But what I do is I start off and I walk uphill very slowly for 20 to 25 minutes,
low grade physical activity for about 20 to 25 minutes,
we'll produce,
exercised induced transient hypofrontality.
It's going to deactivate the prefrontal cortex.
We all know this,
right?
You go to the gym,
you work out for about 2025 minutes.
It gets quiet upstairs,
right?
I then run uphill.
I run up cliff faces or you could just sprint if you want.
And I do it for about five minutes or until I'm in pain basically.
And then I sort of slow it down and you will get endorphins and Amanda Mine,
which are pain relievers,
um,
among other things.
And then I turn around and I run back downhill trying to move my feet faster
than they would normally move without gravity.
Right?
So they're big leaps down that mountain.
Whenever you take a risk you get dopamine.
And so by the time on back down on my path and I'm walking home,
I've mimicked all essentially a bunch of the neurobiology of flow.
It's not 100%,
it doesn't work all the time,
but pretty much it'll put you into a low grade flow state.
And I do this between work sessions and it takes,
you know,
about 45 minutes and I try to like do my problem solving on the way home cause
I'm in a low grade flow state and I've got heightened learning and creativity
and pattern recognition.
And so if there was something that I wasn't doing in my,
you know,
writing,
I got stuck somewhere.
That's when I try to solve it because I'm going to,
I know I'm going to be in a low grade close date.
I think that's a great place to end.
Thanks guys.